'CAUSE IT'S, LIKE,
MY MAIN PET PEEVE.
I KNOW I'VE BEEN GONE
FOR A NUMBER OF HOURS,
BUT MY LIFE HAS
REALLY CHANGED IN THAT TIME.
I LOVE YOU ALL, AND I HOPE I CAN
BE A GOOD MAN LIKE YOU ALL ARE.
- C-CZAR.
- LIZ.
- OH, MY GOD,
I LOVE YOUR GOLDEN HAT.
MM.
BUT LISTEN, LIKE, HATS ASIDE,
I HEARD THE NOTE
THAT YOU TIED
TO MY NIECE DENISE.
YOU PROVED TO, LIKE,
THE ENTIRE WORLD
AND THE TELEVISION AUDIENCE
THAT, LIKE,
YOU'RE MORE THAN A DAD.
- I LOVE YOU.
- WELL, I BASICALLY HAVE,
LIKE, DEEP FEELINGS FOR YOU.
AND, LIKE, I WANT YOU
TO KNOW THAT, LIKE,
AT THIS POINT--
[farts]
[clears throat]
- WHAT?
- LIKE, AT THIS POINT--
[farts, squeals]
LIKE, AT THIS POINT--[farts]
OH, MY GOD.
I THINK I'M GOING INTO LABOR
AT THIS POINT.
THAT WASN'T HOW
THE SENTENCE WAS GONNA END,
BUT LIKE, I DO THINK I'M GOING
INTO LABOR AT THIS POINT.
'SCUSE ME FOR ONE MOMENT.
- OH, SNAP. NO, I'LL COME WITH.
- I NEED TO PUSH IT OUT
LIKE A DOODIE.
[toilet flushing, baby crying]
OH, MY GOD, THANK YOU.
- WELL? WHAT IS IT?
- IT'S A TOILET BABY.
- SO I KNOW IT'S MINE!
- BORN INTO THE TOILET.
- LET'S SMOKE BLUNTS!
[piano music]
- ♪ HOO...
[doorbell rings]
- HEY, GORGEOUS.
- HI.
- ♪ THANK YOU
FOR BEING MY DADDY ♪
♪ THANK YOU
FOR BEING MY FATHER ♪
♪ I THANK YOU
♪